Justin Bieber without eyebrows and a hungry
shirt.
It's episode 42 of IMG!
The lines on the carpet of this game
store produce the illusion of pockets and
dips. If you're still not dizzy,
take a swig from your Full House
flask and then wall down a poppy sandwich
or eat a cat or go to New York
and get yourself a big cat.
But let's be honest,
what you really want is a team of cats that serves
as your hair,
because the only thing more delicious
than cat boogers are panda boogers.
This
image never seems to end, nor does this
one, where a picture was taken
every hour and held next to the next
hour. The world's least portable
MP3 player at least makes more sense than this,
though it's all trumped by chair-chair.
Skull chair.
Obama and Biden
love watching IMG!
Maybe they like my beard,
'cause if so, they should know about the best beard
ever.
If you extrapolate a Barbie doll's proportions
to a woman six feet tall, she would look
like this. Oh, sorry, no, no, no, she would
look like
this. And now, thanks to BuzzFeed,
pictures taken at just the right moment
Here's a rainbow cleverly organizing all the colors
offered by Crayola since 1903.
At first,
you have these 8 colors,
but as time went on, the colors branched,
divided, more and more were offered.
And on the actual site,
you can mouse over each color for its official name.
This infographic is also neat.
The highest to the lowest. It shows
altitude above the death zone,
where humans can't breathe,
all the way down to Denver, Colorado,
the world's tallest building,
under sea levels to the Midnight zone,
the wreckage of the Titanic
and deeper. Oh, and here's one that breaks
down the stats behind
the words used on the Beatles'
"Abbey Road" album.
Teach your kids the importance of athletics. No!
Ffffound.com showed me some sweet pics -
Atari, Atari, fire heart.
In London this morning,
on my way to work, I beat
the universe by finding the Waldo family reunion.
They have great vehicle registration
plates here across the pond and no, no, no, no,
not that one. This one. But seriously,
their numbering scheme is interesting, so if
you want something to geek out about today,
go learn it.
And, as we exit, let's look at
"an exit," a guy running to the door...
Or maybe it's a flying man
wearing a cape, with a giant...
And as always,
thanks for watching.